[Music]
Jepsen's milord is considered by a lot
of people to be the most horrible liquor
they've ever had to me milord
tastes like sweaty socks metallic pine
needles cantaloupe plus tires like
rubber technically it's like a DJ's beef
realistically sour and regret it's
pretty rough but then it's a acquired
taste that now that I can't actually get
enough up
my name is Tremaine Atkinson I am CEO
and head distiller for ch distillery my
best description of the taste of
Jepsen's milord is ass gas and fire all
at the same time I personally love it
and I think it tastes great but maybe
I'm a little weird when a CEO describes
his product is something that tastes
like ass gas and fire it's safe to
assume that there's a story that needs
to be told and that story as it turns
out is one of legend Mille art was
invented in the 1930s by Carl Jefferson
a Swedish immigrant who smoked so many
cigars that it killed his taste buds so
he had to come up with something with
such a strong flavor that it could cut
through and give him a real experience
so do tell where did he come up with we
can say that it does have wormwood in it
and that is its primary flavor and
everything else after that is top secret
but please it's more about wormwood
wormwood is a plant it's really an herb
it looks a little bit just like a twig
with some small leaves on it it grows
just about everywhere when you take a
bite of it it is the most bitter
substance that you really ever could
could bite into please excuse my naivete
but can someone please explain why why
would anyone drink this stuff Jepsen's
malort is an old-school Chicago
tradition Chicago has some really iconic
things about it like deep-dish pizza and
the bean and Lake Michigan I think why
malort is so embraced is because those
other things are nice but milord is kind
of the badass icon of Chicago it it
allows us to be ourselves I wanted to
get involved with milord ever since I
started making booze here in Chicago
because it is such a staple of the
Chicago drinking scene
staple more like an anti staple how many
shots of this could you possibly sell on
average 365 days a year people are
taking 10,000 shots of malort so think
about that every night 10,000 shots of
Mille art are disappearing into people's
bodies that's a really weird way to say
that weird indeed but point made I
vaguely remember my first shot of milord
same I remember my friend who was from
here said oh you gotta try a shot of
this and I took it and I just said hi
why did you do that to me that was how I
was introduced to it but now I love
milord because I love the way it tastes
I think it is fascinating I love the
balance between the pure bitterness and
the herbal and floral flavors that
little touch of sweetness the heat of
the alcohol all of that adds up to me is
a really really interesting taste
experience and I also love the way it
makes me feel I love the way that you
love milord and I only wish that one day
I will be so lucky to love something as
much as you love your beloved milord
[Music]
[Music]
in the southern part of Croatia in the
peninsula of paljah Zak there is a
winemaker that does things a little
differently I mean by Odin a president
we know is promoter that's right this
winery ages their wine 75 feet beneath
the sea surface after growing up around
many traditional winemakers Edie had an
idea to combine his two favorite
pastimes scuba diving and drinking wine
so he decided to try an aged wine in the
sea when I do just a movie no ob9 140
Kotaku
polygons a memorial to avoid any leaks
in these ancient storage jars
edy uses a glass bottle to keep the wine
in and saltwater out he uses custom-made
cages that line the sea floor to hold
the wine in place both estoy bonito worn
ideal crystal not known a primadonna
respond oh dear no podía God in any
cotton Adira
allo Bettina chassis previous occupant
nested on assess Dharana the semi
destroy a cocoon a state
[Music]
temperatura McCoy Sweden as of the
javanese semolina eastern a version of
inertia WT silly party Sheena
Jelena fact or ask me but Jenny mudati
Anu no to appear conclusion Avena and
CET it's this silence that
differentiates his unique underwater
wine from the pack Santos Josephine
Potter Bhima token godina Sarada
Bodhisattva tunic a primitive a
dishonest or adovada Sinestro Dimitra
permit it is vuko be questioned Raja
Padma silvano Tetsu
yep Tennessee organism una a novena vino
da ba da gachi a pony oak whose negative
II know what's normal or pakalana
me llamo was it a tear as Acosta Kaka
logical shoe bas Rutten business was pop
was not his familiarity
signature of I primarily acrylic auras
what if I told you alcohol could make
you live longer for the residents of a
small Japanese island that seems to hold
true
known as the island of longevity
tokunoshima
is home to the world's highest
percentage of people living beyond 100
years legend has it the reason people
are living longer is a special kind of
Japanese spirit called shochu
made only by local distillers
in receipts rocks see what washes over
closet again dr. Cocteau shirts
clippings Madoka neat mo khayrat tiana
so to the night show - no naka de mo
kamo Amami Oshima Guntur - Scott says Oh
Lucas r18 I showed you octo teen
demeanor a mine that up to you image the
Animas Jewish mascara for boomer but the
Giro nan desu kedo the hurricane girl no
closer to no food [ __ ] nobody must know
day Osaka he once took a wine talking
Akiko height build a casino he know mr.
Cheetham Oh Amory no Khurana Noah Jolie
she no show - yeah so - kissing she no
cutter Mario - castle coconut 30 toka
he's only put four even overall compared
to you he Tony cara de I recorded know
me wanna tell you we need you are acting
smart even as IQ sohcahtoa easily she
get your son to discover much dead more
my vanity bands are consolidated so you
me they were chosen or Staton all those
on adaptive and like
[Music]
she wanna stop what's the matter Lois
Keenan is now too much so no wanna Konya
kannada aarti octo Sheffield multi-value
our token or any order to decide relate
to Barney's vodka always a good choice
strong smooth delightfully clear vodka
is usually made from potatoes grapes or
wheat one man is doing things
differently
he's making vodka from yes you heard
that right
sheep we are in birches bay in tasmania
australia 16 years ago my family might
built our sheep cheesery from scratch I
was getting tired of just doing the sort
of cheese things and so I came up with
the idea of distilling matter how by
using away so way is essentially part of
cheese making and in a lot of cases put
down the drain and wasted I have figured
out a way to turn that into a product
making vodka from whey is quite unusual
there had been a couple of successful
attempts but no one had ever made a
sheep's way vodka until Ryan came along
it took him about a hundred attempts
over the course of a year but he got
there so step one we milk the sheep and
then give it to our cheese factory who
then makes it into a cheese and then the
way is what's left over
step two I grabbed that way and then
adding enzymes it ferments into alcohol
what essentially creates alcohol is a
basic sugar and my basic sugar is
lactose step 3
I grab that alcohol and distill it twice
into a finished spirit and step four I
age the spirit for four months Step five
we actually hand
paint the entire bottle so we spray the
black on and then we hand write so that
every bottle is unique start to finish
from milking the Sheep all the way to
bottling the product it would take at
least five months you'll smell a lot of
sweetness coming through from the milk
and then when you drink it it's gonna be
really creamy on the palate and always
have a little milky sort of finished one
of the biggest awards that we won was
world's best vodka which was huge for us
in vodka is not the end for Ryan's
distilling experiments he's also
ventured into gin and now to cue us out
how'd you drink it so treat it really
really similar to a whiskey just nice
and neat even with no ice that's great
that's really smooth it's real glass hmm
beautiful very nice very good dream this
is definitely beautiful beautiful to the
palate
[Music]